hi my name's Scott Williamson I'm the
CEO of the mega center alien active
Christian trust just first of all I want
to say thank you the Rochford
coronavirus action line is something
that we set up in partnership with many
community leaders with watch or district
council and church is just to help
people in our community I want to say to
you in Rochford district if you need
some help don't hesitate to call us Oh 1
2 6 8 double 7 double 9 double 9 we are
here to help you we're here to help you
with food and medicine we're here to
help you just to be a supportive person
on the end of the phone to help you in
this really difficult time I want to say
thank you so much to all those
volunteers in our district that are
helping for those over a hundred people
that are taking phone calls for us every
day Monday to Sunday and thank you so
much for doing out for over 200
volunteers that are helping in our
district deliver medicine and food
I want to say thank you so much for
doing that for me it's a delight because
as the mega Center really we exist and
to help people in our community in our
charity called active Christian trust
and it's a pleasure for me as a CEO to
be involved as a volunteer myself in
this initiative in this time of crisis
to help so thank you for all the
volunteers that are helping if you still
want to help just please make contact
with us with our email below thank you
and God bless